life expectancy's been declining yeah
the last few years how do we reverse
that Trend these are the five safest
things to do Dr Decker Keltner a
renowned expert in the science of human
emotion discovering ways on how we can
improve our happiness he's also the
author of several books including the
power paradox
I read just someone touching you can
make you live longer and be less
stressed is that true yeah there are all
kinds of findings that speak to this you
have premature babies they used to just
put them in these little units that warm
them and they would die and then they
figured out they needed skin-to-skin
contact like they need food and they
live they gained 47 weight gain you know
the deepest craving we have is to be
appreciated by other people
you want to be happy practice compassion
and if you want others to be happy
practice compassion if I am kind to you
my act of kindness makes you more kind
Downstream and then that person you've
helped actually is Kinder to another
person and they've proven that yeah so
that karma is a very real thing it's
very real that'll save eight ten years
of life you've got to find a few moments
just to be kind are we worst people the
Richer and more powerful we've become
yeah so we've actually done experiments
right you know it's a movie about a
child who has cancer and poor people
show activation to vagus nerve which is
part of compassion well-to-do people
less activation the wealthier you are
the more you navigate it for serious
economic policies that hurt the poor
Jesus and this is where it gets really
works then
I just want to start this episode with a
message of thanks a thank you to
everybody that Tunes in to listen to
this podcast by doing so you've enabled
me to live out my dream but also for
many members of our team to live out
their dreams too it's one of the
greatest privileges I could never have
dreamed of or imagined in my life to get
to do this to get to learn from these
people to get to have these
conversations to get to interrogate them
from a very selfish perspective trying
to solve problems I have in my life so I
feel like I owe you a huge thank you for
being here and for listening to these
episodes and for making this platform
what it is can I ask you a favor I can't
tell you how much you can change the
course of this podcast the the course of
the guests were able to invite to the
show and to the course of everything
that we do here just by doing one simple
thing and that simple thing is hitting
that subscribe button helps this channel
more than I could ever explain the
guests on this platform are incredible
because so many of you have hit that
button and I know when we think about
what we want to do together over the
next year on this show a lot of it is
going to be fueled by the amount of you
that are subscribed in that tune in to
this show every week so thank you let's
keep doing this I can't wait to see what
this year brings for this show for us as
a community and for this platform
[Music]
could you start by giving me your
professional
academic resume
uh wow well that it begins early with my
parents who were you know very important
in my education and my formation so my
dad is a visual artist and my mom taught
literature and poetry and Romanticism
and got me interested in
you know all kinds of things about the
human mind
um and then I was at UC Santa Barbara as
an undergraduate and then went to
Stanford for PhD subsequent to that
worked with Paul Ekman as a postdoc
who's
kind of a Pioneer in the study of facial
expression uh and inspiration for the
show lie to me and then became a
professor uh Wisconsin uh and then UC
Berkeley for 27 years and helped run the
greater good science center which is
about disseminating
kind of the new knowledge of meditation
and compassion and stress to a broad
audience and have taught at Berkeley
which I love for 27 years you reference
at a greater good science center yeah
what's the what's the mission of the
greater good science center yeah thanks
for asking you know um 20 years ago uh
post 911
um you know we were in a world much like
post Trump and uh Boris Johnson and
others you know like are we are we
fragmented what happened to humanity
um what happened to community
um why are life expectancies in the
United States dropping the last two
years what's going on right so I saw
that yeah striking right really
disturbing
um and we had the conviction and there
was this new science of things like if
you have strong social ties it adds 10
years of life expectancy to your life
right if you practice kindness
um it quiets down the threat regions of
the brain and so we at Berkeley
in partnership with the journalism
School kind of had the sense early like
if we can get this knowledge out right
inactionable Pros where you read it and
you say oh I could teach breathing to my
my medical team or I could teach an aw
walk to my neighborhood friends uh that
would be good for the world you know I'm
super compelled by that thank you the
Great's a good science center can you
let's talk about some of the things that
you've you've given away in terms of
knowledge and some of the sort of
discoveries that I think would surprise
most people you mentioned some of them
in passing there yeah about breathing
and all walks and
um how you can add 10 years to your life
yeah what give me some of the top line
um more detail on some of those Top Line
findings
this really comes into Focus for me
Stephen when I speak to Medical
audiences I do a lot of work with
Healthcare Providers
um you know teaching medical doctors
residents
uh helping programmatically with
kind of the spirit of hospitals and the
like
um I talk about uh awe that the feeling
of awe
reduces activation in the inflammation
system in your immune system your immune
system is all these cells distributed
throughout your body that helps you
protect against dangerous elements on
the outside viruses and bacteria and the
feeling of awe sort of reduces the
activation of the cytokine system which
heats up your body and if your body is
always hot that is bad news for your
heart it's bad news for your diabetes
and awe helps moderate that I
um you know I teach the work on
compassion that you know 65 year olds
who practice altruism and compassion uh
have greater life expectancy
um you know and you can go on each of
these what used to be thought of as kind
of new age
soft things like awe or Compassion or
breathing benefit us you know just
simple breathing if you breathe in and
out counting to four as you breathe in
counting out to four actually increases
neural density in the this part of your
brain the prefrontal cortex which helps
you handle stress what is all for
someone yeah Oz just feeling an emotion
you have when you encounter something
big or vast that's outside of your frame
of reference right of reality that you
don't understand that I I think I like
the word mystery uh you know wow who I
can't figure this out and and then that
emotion of awe stimulates Wonder right
like how do I why do people why do
rainbows exist what you know how are
they produced when water when light
bends through water molecules so it's
it's an emotion that drives wonder and
creativity what is the
um positive net impact on humans of
experiencing or other than because when
I think of ore I think of going to like
Machu Picchu and seeing those big
mountains yeah what the hell is this
this is insane and I think of that as
being like a memory oh that's fun that's
amazing I take the picture yeah put it
on my Instagram get the likes go home
yeah but there's something deeper going
on right physiology yeah thank you you
know one of the fascinating things
Stephen when you're you know is when you
study this complicated realm of emotion
is we have these words that we all use
to talk about an emotion and they're
much as we have words about you know
ethnic categories or class categories
always lower class or he's he's
African-American those are just words
and Concepts that may not capture
reality at all and awe
suffers from this which is when people
talk about awe or they share it on
Instagram they show they share the big
moments of like I was at the Grand
Canyon or I was in the Lake District or
by this Cathedral
um but in point of fact you know there
are a lot of ways in which we feel awe
all the time right uh encountering
somebody who's really kind in the
streets you're like wow that was really
generous so yesterday on the train the
team were coming up to Manchester where
I was speaking and a an elderly lady
overheard them saying that they were
going to climb a mountain for charity
the elderly lady got up walked over gave
him five pounds and said I climbed that
once his five pounds put it towards the
charity and for all of us it went into
our like company chat that that happened
it was a real moment of like an
affirmation of what it is to be a human
and kindness I guess yeah and what's
stunning to me and this is a digression
is your story just gave me the chills
yeah yeah and that's amazing it's very
incredible isn't it it is incredible
that I wasn't there I've just got the
chills myself just yeah just saying you
have the chills it's just giving me this
it's amazing and that we don't
understand scientifically the contagious
power of chills and all but you know all
it it's not the stereotype that we are
led to understand or think about with
words it's around us all the time right
the generosity and the Train the
beautiful clouds a piece of music a
visual design you know driving here to
your studio all the incredible design of
London it's around us
um and so it's there every day and you
know Stephen I I'm not a uh I don't know
why this happened to me but I've taught
happiness to hundreds of thousands of
people online and in classes and the
like I was a grouchy kid stressed out
most of my life terrible meditator but I
was forced into this job and you know
serving the science of Happiness we've
been talking about man two minutes of
awe every other day is about as good for
you as anything you can do you know it
calms stress calm stress regions of your
brain
talked about inflammation it reduces
inflammation activates the vagus nerve
which is this bundle of nerves the
wanders all throughout your body and
calms your heart rate it's good for
digestion so you know it's good news for
the human psyche and when we talk about
giving a little stressed out 12 year old
young 12 year old some awe each moment
in a classroom we know that's really
good for health and creativity so
um it's good news in terms of what it
can bring to us
talk to me about some some science then
um that supports that assertion where
yeah the science shows that every day or
so like accessible or yeah the all that
I could go get out in the street or that
I could actively go practice after
listening to this conversation yeah has
proven to have a positive physiological
impact on humans or their emotions or
their behavior yeah
yeah you know this was one of the most
exciting developments of the science of
our
um
when we started to get this picture of
the health benefits of less stress a
sense of time reduce loneliness right
loneliness 40 of people in globalized
cultures feel lonely right that is hard
on the body we started to think about
all interventions
um and you know one of my favorites uh
that has compelling Health Data if you
will is
um
a lot of people go for regular walks the
UK is famous for its walking Traditions
you know it's one of the great cultural
strengths you know just paths and you
know and walks and you know Etc and and
uh so we just added one element to
people's regular walk uh and we called
it the ah walk which is when you go out
pause take some breathing deep breathing
get synced up with your footsteps this
is a classic kind of walking meditation
approach and then look for awe right
look take a moment to look at small
things look at the reflection on this
cool mug then pan out and look at you
know the vastness of where you are City
or nature up at the sky that was it
right and that gets you into this ah
mindset and our participants were 75
years old or older
um at that age a lot of data suggests
you start getting more anxious and
depressed right your people you love are
dying your body's falling apart you are
facing your mortality and they all walk
over eight weeks once a week compared to
a really rigorous control condition LED
our 75 years old participants to feel
less distress
less pain and more awe and joy in their
lives so it's just this simple addition
to a daily walk right
listening to some music do it more
intentionally and and a lot of the
studies of awe are really simple you
know just watching all video share an
off story which you shared to me that
just gave me the Goosebumps you know
that Goosebumps is a register it's these
little muscles around hair follicles
that are part of what are called your
parasympathetic autonomic nervous system
which calm you down so share stories of
all so so there's a ton of ways in which
you can build more everyday awe into
your life what's the evolutionary basis
for this
um
the you know in 1978 I think Richard
Dawkins published selfish Gene massive
book right you know if you read that
it's it the argument which is true is
there we are the we have these genes
that are replicating themselves through
us we are these machines that replicate
genes right uh and all of our
characteristics are ways to do that and
and it's all the language is very
aggressive and adversarial these genes
are competing with these genes I'm
competing with other people in the game
of evolution and there's been this
massive shift in evolutionary thinking
in the past 40 years where you know
we're just starting to discover you know
around the world people share 40 to 50
percent of a resource with a stranger if
asked just like as a default that's our
intuition
um we have neurophysiological systems
like oxytocin parts of the brain and the
vagus nerve which help us sacrifice and
give we readily
we are contagious in our feelings your
story gave me the chills and then my
chills bounced back to you and you got
the chills so we're United and connected
and now you know it it the thinking is
we're very Cooperative alongside violent
and rapacious and the like and and
Collective we're hyper Collective
um we synchronize with each other
physiologically we mimic each other we
collaborate unlike any other primate
we're that's just who we are it's
probably our big strength
um I think because in part
um hyper vulnerable Offspring needed a
lot of care right to live
food scarcity warming in the face of
cold and we need
emotions and social practices that make
us feel like we're Collective and awe is
it when you know it's it's so striking
Stephen I don't know if you've had in
our experience in nature recently
just being outdoors oh yeah I mean yeah
so I went to I went to Bali in Indonesia
to write my book in Ubud and that's one
of the places where I mean you're in a
vast jungle yeah but also whenever you
get to top of a mountain you look out
across the jungle and I remember one
particular moment looking out across the
jungle stood on this platform that was
awe-inspiring yeah but also it's quite
weird that I my awe-inspiring
experiences in that country are always
just being on the moped and going
through the countryside yeah because
this because it's this it feels like the
essence of nature there's something
about I don't know what it is there's
there's this realness to it that makes
me feel like I'm at home it's hard to
explain but and that's
feel like you're at home right and it's
striking think about it conceptually
like here I am on a moped in nature with
you know the the ecosystems kind of
moving into my body and my brain and out
of that comes the concept I'm home and
that's what awe does is it says I'm part
of this people right the other the other
time was actually last week I was at
SoHo Farmhouse which is a sort of like a
uh like a hotel Village they've
constructed where you can go on the
weekend to be in nature and it was
actually walking back to my cabin I
looked up up for the first time and
obviously when you're in the countryside
yeah you get to see the stars in London
you don't have that I'm not sure no and
I looked up and I saw the stars and I
started talking like having a mental
conversation about what that is like
what I'm looking at that is a I mean
that one over there is a bigger than
planet Earth and it's I'm basically this
tiny little into seemingly insignificant
piece of irrelevant dust and that made
me feel a sense of all the feeling is
really
because I am so small I am part of this
bigger thing yeah you know when you
don't look up and when you're looking
down let's say figuratively
there's a sort of an individualism yeah
whereas like it's it's me yeah I'm the
center of the universe when you look up
you realize that you are irrelevant but
therefore also part of this greater
thing I guess yeah thank you for
bringing that up you know and one of the
simple actionable things that we've been
teaching at greater good we have a
practice on this is look at the sky just
like look up take a minute if you ask
the average citizen in a city like
London when's the last time you looked
at the sky right yeah I don't see it
yeah and it's powerful yeah the you know
one of the paradoxical qualities of awe
and and is this
shift this transformation and sense of
self that you're talking about and it's
profound which is you know in the s in
one of the early writing Traditions
around awe which is spiritual journaling
a lot of people early accounts of awe
and the bhagavad-gita and Julian of
Norwich and you know the great Christian
writings almost every spiritual
tradition the Buddha uh it's this like
God I'm having this ecstatic ah mystical
experience what's it like and they write
about the uh the self just like
Vanishing you know
psychedelics has a rich tradition of ego
death in it Carl Sagan it has this great
statement about space like yours like
man when I think about the universe
look at me I'm just asleep yeah yeah I'm
a little speck of dust you know but the
self is huge in our minds yeah and ah
quiet said it puts it into perspective
and what's striking Stephen which you
know it took us a long time to figure
this out scientifically is
it actually feels liberating you know oh
it's the you know what when I'm stressed
I remind myself of how insignificant I
am because stress is often the like the
um the like the Fatal decision to
overestimate the significance of your
your problems like relative to you know
to whatever but the other day I was I
was a little bit um I was overthinking
something a lot and I could feel myself
getting a little bit stressed and I
reminded myself of looking down on a
plane yeah over a country and just how
irrelevant I am in the grand scheme of
things because of you know I became a
dragon on the on Dragon's Den and the
podcast became bigger you know it's it's
easy sometimes to fall into the Trap of
when there's a lot of people talking
about you or writing about you to to to
think that this is the center of the
universe in some respect I'm leading a
movement of two million people yeah but
whenever I go up in a plane and I look
down I go nothing that I do is really
math matters in a good way yeah it's
funny because it's a paradox it's like I
want to be empowered and I want to think
that I matter yeah but at the same time
I I like to realize that I absolutely
don't matter in any respect and I love
saying this to people because it you can
see that kind of their ego Square yeah
when you go when you put in context that
we are as an individual we absolutely
don't matter you know in the in the
millions or whatever billions of years
that the Universe has existed we are
just This Blink and I'm just this
irrelevant Speck of dust and once I'm
gone you know give it another million
years no one's even gonna remember yeah
or whatever probably a couple of years
but but that's what's great about I on
the human mind right is we we need the
ego and the self and we need to maximize
our interests and desires and
reproductive possibilities Etc status
you know all that obsessive stuff but
man we have this great realm of
transcendence that awe is part of that
you know in our studies you know we we
literally we took students up to the
tower on the UC Berkeley campus they got
to look out at the the and they no
longer felt stressed about things we had
students look up into trees and just
admire these we have a lot of tall trees
on campus and I hope you visited
sometime that are beautiful and tall and
make you feel like you know they're we
have redwood trees that are a thousand
years old you know that oh
this little moment of Consciousness that
is so self-critical or
or stressed or or ego maniacal is just a
moment in time of seven nine billion
people it's you know for me personally
it was liberating to find this in awe
like like you're saying like
this is all this is just one human's
effort so
why did you write this book
of all the things you could have written
about you're a very smart individual
you've studied so many things relating
to sort of social sciences and how
humans behave and why we why we do what
we do but to commit your life to writing
a book about this subject matter yeah is
writing books is not easy yeah it takes
a long time a lot of effort yeah to
promote them Etc why this book why now
yeah
thank you for asking that
um
yeah you know
um it is hard to write books and we had
done a lot of research on awe and
you know one of the reasons I wrote the
book was
um
you know I'm now at an age where I've
been following how we're doing as
cultures and and a lot of the things
that have surfaced here Stephen are true
like you know
people feel lonely they feel
um
adrift they're circing they're searching
for something more meaningful than
elevating a paycheck and and I felt that
awe was part of that story that all gets
us to what is Meaningful to us is
individuals at a moment in history
um and then
uh my younger brother died and he
um he was he was born I'm one year older
we had this wild childhood you know of
like born in Mexico and raised in the
late 60s in Laurel Canyon a very
experimental Place wandering the
foothills of the Sierras and
and uh he was
my source of meaning in many ways in
life
um and he got colon cancer and died
and it was brutal and horrifying and at
the moment of his dying uh the last
night he uh sitting by his bed
and
um and he he was my moral compass in
life you know he really he was very
courageous
super kind I really only cared about
like devoted his career to the least
uh resource kids in the country these
four poor kids and um
when I was watching him die
uh I had an awe experience I was like
you know what is going on he seems
really calm
he's heading into a space I don't
understand I saw like pulsating light
you know that was uniting everyone
around him in this sense of reverence
and
the sacredness of his life and uh
afterward
um I was knocked into a really profound
state of grief where
um this about five years ago
uh I couldn't make sense of the world
you know I could do my work
um
but I just did I was lost because he was
a very important voice to me
you know and I was waking up wasn't
sleeping panicky and and I like a lot of
people in grief I was like
you know hallucinating like I would see
him follow a guy in the streets like and
he wasn't him
I'd wake up thinking he was there I felt
his hand on my back a couple times
and uh
it was weird I was I had this Epiphany
in this really bad State of Mind the
worst I've ever felt like
um I gotta find awe again you know I
have to my brother
you know he and I went dancing and did
wild things and backpacking and you know
just live this life of awe he was my
source and he was gone
um and so I wrote the book you know and
I I dug in and just started writing
about him
and he features prominently in the book
you know what he meant to me and how I
grieved his loss and then worked up the
science too so in many ways you know
what we're observing in our our
globalized culture is is this the
problems of capitalism the search for
meaning the you know Rising the reduced
life expectancy U.S Rising anxiety
depression
and I was kind of in that state you know
suddenly like wow my career is good but
uh you know and so
um knowing a little bit about the
science I was like I've got to do this
myself and go get it did you find that
war again I did it it
it it took a lot of work you know I was
in a really tough place and uh you know
I
um I just was I just started Anew like
where do I find meaning and I find
meaning working with prisoners
I don't know why you know
um but just you know being in prisons
volunteering helping with the formerly
incarcerated
I challenged myself to
find on places I wouldn't ordinarily
find it like just to open my mind like
whoa I'm at a symphony you know I love
African music and Sona Joe barte and you
know and here I was in the symphony not
understanding it but starting to feel it
um you know nature is easy for me I've
always backpacked and gone into the
mountains I had a lot of spiritual
conversations you know of like I'm not a
religious person
and I was like what is this you know why
why mystical also and what it gave me I
think with respect to my brother's death
is an openness like we don't know what
life is we don't know where it goes we
don't you know uh and it opened my mind
to a lot of new sources of awe
there's almost an injustice I had in
that story because of the way you
characterized your brother and his
behavior yeah for him then to have
passed early from cancer yeah feels in
many respects to me like the opposite of
or or you know the universe being uh
compassionate or fair or whatever and
that yeah yeah it hit me hard you know
it was uh and that's what I put like for
the first year
you know you you ask these questions
like why would a guy
who teaches speech therapy to the
poorest kids in the United States go and
his with a teenage daughter and a young
family come on you know come on and
Donald Trump is you know indestructible
and you're like the world is you
know and and I grappled with that
uh very hard and then I was as you well
put I was in this antithesis
state of awe I was like nothing meant
anything
you know it was all pointless
I could sense nothing bigger about life
that mattered
and that's why you know that's why I
said all right
I have this career that allows me to do
these investigations and we're all
investigating we're all cert see
searching for these things in music or
moral beauty or being in collectives or
Sports and I just threw myself into it
and and uh
and you know frankly
um
it you know the idea of everyday awe
which is very important in the book we
can find it anywhere you know on the
train with the act of generosity that is
now it just feels alive all the time
what's kind of the through line to
gratitude because when you were talking
about the whole question when you picked
up this
um mug the silver mug we have in front
of us yeah and you started admiring it
it almost sounded a bit more like
gratitude to me yeah and even the the
study where you had the elderly
participants do the walk and then sort
of self-report I'm guessing on how they
felt yeah it sounded like nature also
gives us a sense of sort of gratitude
for our lives for the way we live in
yeah what's the distinction or
difference if there is one yeah what a
terrific question and there's a deep
philosophical tradition
um of David David Hume Scottish
philosopher
um Charles Darwin Martha Nussbaum more
recently a Chicago philosopher that we
and it really animates a lot of this
conversation the work I've done is like
we have these amazing emotions that are
like deep intuitions about the world
that are good for us and good for the
world you know compassion take care of
people who are vulnerable oh you know
connect to others to face fast mystery
and gratitude Adam Smith the great
Economist felt like this is the emotion
that holds societies together gratitude
the feeling of reverence for things are
like wow this is really important and
sacred of things that are given to you
and that is key like oh my friend helped
me with my work
um my work colleague brought me lunch
um you know my my child did the dishes
tonight you know whoa I feel grateful
gratitude really close to awe as as you
into it but it tends to be different in
that awe tends to be about vaster things
like you know
uh you almost get into a car crash or
you get into a car crash you almost die
and you're like I'm just I feel
awestruck that I'm alive you know and
then awe has more mystery to it you
can't understand it like music or right
like music yeah exactly you know music
rushes into you
and you start crying right and you're
like oh my God so what's a recent
experience of that for you
of music yeah
um it would be where you just start
sobbing and you know or not oh something
or chills
it would be we do this live show for
it's called the driver CEO live and we
toured the country last year we did
three nights at the Palladium then we
took it to all these theaters and I'm
stood and there's a house Gospel Choir
of about 40 people behind me for the
whole two hours while I'm speaking and I
mean Jesus yeah facing a lot of
like just songs as part of the message
that I'm conveying and I mean every
night I'm
you know I'm crying it's funny because I
rehearsed it I rehearsed it I practiced
I practiced it but then with the people
there the audience of 2500 people and
the choir that I would cry every night
yeah which is bizarre which is strange
isn't it striking it's a sense of
connectedness maybe I wonder why in the
live show when there's thousands of
people there then I feel the most
intense emotions yeah versus when we're
in rehearsals yeah
that's a complicated question but your
examples tell us you know that you the
vastness of that experience of like wow
there are sound waves that I'm producing
that are moving bodies I see this
pattern of movement and I am part of
that and as the poet Ross gay says these
boundaries between self and other become
very porous you're like Whoa We are one
organism that's awe vast and and I don't
understand why gratitude is more you
know you're at the show and you know
somebody looks you in the eye and smiles
and and you feel like they're grateful
for you it has this more readily
understood economy to it almost or
um and why you know in writing about awe
um the you know there are some things
that are intuitive like oh nature makes
us feel awe and people's moral Beauty
and kindness your story on the train
but how in the world music
sound waves hits our ear produces a
neurochemistry in the brain and the next
thing you know you're crying you know
and feeling one
that's amazing to me and we still I
don't know if science will ever answer
it you know it's it's just the
Transcendent power of music and you're
lucky to share it do you have any
insight into the positive impact that
gratitude has on US based on any sort of
studies that have been done it's huge
and you know Stephen like when following
and teaching the science of Happiness
literature for 25 years you know at UC
Berkeley I started teaching a happiness
course I think it was Harvard and us for
the first 25 years ago tracking like
what are the what are the things you can
count on you know and when I go out and
teach happiness
um it's very humbling like you asked me
in some sense
um a related question to have a parent
come up to me and say you know my son is
massively depressed and suicidal what do
I do you know and obviously you go see a
therapist and you consider medication
but the happiness literature can point
to like these are the five
safest things to do social connection
develop some way to
use your body to calm down breathing
yoga Sports whatever and gratitude as a
winner and I think Oz up there now too
but you know gratitude
practicing gratitude uh benefits the
cardiovascular system it helps people
who have heart vulnerabilities patience
they do better
it is very good for your place in social
networks like I join a group
I'm I'm worried I'm socially anxious
what do I do practice some gratitude you
know say thank you and uh show a little
appreciation of people you will have
stronger social ties we did research
showing it's good for romantic bonds you
know the if Partners simply say on
occasion like hey thanks for doing the
dishes or I appreciate how you the jokes
you tell or I love your music selection
it helps right so it's it's a safe bet
for a happier life you know this I've
come to learn that there's so many
forces in our day-to-day lives that act
against gratitude yeah and
um stifle its presence but in the
context you've given there whether it's
in a social group or at work or in a
relationship or even with yourself I've
come to learn how important it is to not
rely on gratitude just showing up but to
try and create a system for frequent
gratitude yeah now one of the things
that's been a real unlock for me my
companies over the last couple of years
is in every company that I run
we have a gratitude chat yeah so it's
just a channel yeah and it's open
there's really no instruction but it's
funny that we we created the Channel
first at Social chain and then in my
current companies and when you just
create the channel what happens is
gratitude pours in yeah so today
there'll be I can guarantee at some
point today there'll be a message in
there that says thank you so much Ross
for going and getting me that cup of
coffee
um that I didn't ask for but you knew
that I needed or whatever or thank you
Jack for helping me lift that box
upstairs and it pours in and it's such a
simple thing to do yeah but it creates
this insane
um
um hard to understand amount of like
connectiveness and appreciation yeah I
imagine for the individual on the
receiving end of the gratitude
um a sense of like worthiness or or
respect respect or mine yeah and it's
such a small thing to do it is that I
think every company should consider
which is having a system yeah to move
gratitude friction free yeah across your
organization yeah to back bind it
together but in your purse in your
relationship the same thing yeah like
you can rely on it being a you know your
partner helping you with the bags or
helping you with your packing or
whatever but it would it's great to also
in a relationship have a system for yeah
gratitude and what I love about your
system Stephen you know I've taught
gratitude in a lot of organizational
contexts and sometimes people force it
like you know okay let's see what we're
grateful to
for each person in the in this you know
this meeting and it's like oh God you
know that's tricky but to allow it to be
spontaneous and intuitive like you did
right and let it flow that's that's the
strong source and manifestation of
gratitude and it reminds us you know in
Western European thinking probably
largely Western European male thinking
has been so hostile to emotion uh this
is what I was saying when I said there's
so many forces acting against it yeah
and it's just like
why would you ever say thank you it
makes you weak it makes you vulnerable
and the like Etc but
there are a lot of great thinkers from
David Hume Adam Smith Charles Darwin you
know early a lot of the East Asian you
know contemplative philosophies like
our best human Tendencies come out of
emotions of gratitude and express them
um and and I think that your example
speaks to sort of a big shift culturally
and what do we do with these emotions at
work they're really vital to our sense
of connectivity and community
makes me think a lot about relationships
and I know this is something you've
written about
um extensively the the role that a
romantic relationship plays in health
outcomes etc etc but then I also was um
I was pondering this idea of monogamy
broadly yeah whether so my kind of
question is kind of twofold is yeah are
we meant to be monogamous yeah
um and also
this I'm thinking a lot about how the
relationship Dynamics and Alchemy is
changing in some in some ways uh eroding
yeah I was reading some stats around
marriage and how people are getting
married less yeah you know having less
kids and all these kinds of things yeah
what's your thoughts on all of that are
we meant to be monogamous you've done a
lot of research on apes and yeah you
talked a lot about them in your in your
work yeah but are we meant to be
monogamous
and if so
how does that relate to the fact that
being in a relationship extends our life
what a terrific question well you know
anytime that you pose these questions
right you have to remember
um you know and I always approach things
from an evolutionary framework you know
which is humans are many different kinds
of individuals right there's massive
individual variation and when I
um you know and there's cultural
variation so some cultures will be less
monogamous others more
um yeah I think that I think that
um the the safest answer we can offer
and it's dispiriting and I teach it to
my young students at Berkeley is you
know I hate to tell you this but you're
in love right now but odds are very good
that that's not going to be the last
relationship you're in and so we tend to
move from one semi-committed
relationship to another
um so serial monogamy or uh is is what
many believe to be kind of our default
orientation there's variation around
that some
are more polyamorous others are really
fiercely monogamous given genetic makeup
and cultural makeup
um my belief is
um and and your generation is really
bringing this to the fore which is that
the old model of single monogamous
relationship for 60 years uh probably is
not working when you look at divorce
rates 50 percent
those people who stay together half of
those marriages are really pretty
unhappy so it's it's not working you
look at certain cultures I was struck
Steven recently as you know the
Scandinavians always do really well in
happiness measures right and it's like
and I just Google like you know what is
the um
is sort of living configuration romantic
relationship configuration in Sweden
Sweden has really high rates of people
co-parenting but not living with the
parent right and that may be a model to
be not not living with a partner sorry
um and so I think that we have many
kinds of Love uh one of them being a
monogamous love
um it it puts a lot of pressure to uh
with this old kind of romantic
chivalrous Victorian ideal of like
that's the only person I don't think
that works right and so we're moving
towards more flexible Arrangements where
we express many kinds of love and and it
comes with a lot of complexity so I when
I teach
love I say there are all these kinds of
love right Walt Whitman
love friendship you know I I mean
friendship love and a lot of the data
friends
give you more happiness than any kind of
relationship right oh I shouldn't say I
shouldn't say I agree my girlfriend is
somewhere upstairs
you know I understand yeah I understand
so the I think this this model of like
you know singular devoted all consuming
romantic love is misled us and we need
varieties of romantic love which your
generation is creating which is exciting
and then we need to remember the other
forms to to have the rich life and then
you get at that you know I got the right
social configuration to give me those 10
years of life expectancy
I've always been going back and forth
about marriage because I understand some
people say marriage is a A system that
allows for the rearing of kids yeah um
it's a it's a form of commitment which
changes things in the relationship but
the
but I've always wondered if there's
another way yeah that's more you know
where which kind of I don't know is
there another way like I'm not even sure
me and my partner would get married but
I'm sure we'd make some kind of
commitment to each other but
you know I'm not sure involving the law
in church and all these things in the in
the process is necessarily
conducive with a productive outcome I
know and not only that but just think
about like you know I'm gonna be wait
I'm gonna do everything from physical
exercise to streaming movies to cooking
food with one person right
um you know it's interesting Stephen
um
the there's this really striking
literature you know one of the raw facts
of our evolution is our offspring are
very vulnerable they're the most
vulnerable offspring of any mammal on
the face of the Earth they take seven to
eight to twenty years just to I even say
like 55 years to you know to even be
semi functioning as an individual but
what that meant is love
in our our hominid Evolution was
distributed in communities right and
there's this concept called aloe
parenting which is we all kind of take
care of young ones even if they're not
our own we're all affectionately related
to each other in that work we're all
there's much more sexual fluidity in
that Dynamic that probably reflects the
truth of today that we don't face with
this Victorian ideal of singular
romantic love and and maybe your
generation is moving us toward
that that
sort of more communal approach to love
uh of com and it's complicated right it
involves different ideas about sexuality
and different ideas of caregiving
um but probably healthier and I hope it
happens
why why won't it work and why doesn't it
work because you know when we think
about polygamy or um popping polyamorous
I don't know the difference going to be
honest yeah they sound similar polygamy
multiple wives polyamorous multiple
people you love okay yeah so when we
think about those Pollies yeah
um It seems impossible in the modern
world yeah to execute a poly situation
yeah without jealousy and all the other
yeah and you know I grew up
raised around hippies you know my
parents were Counter Culture I grew up
in Laurel Canyon in the late 60s very
wild place and I saw a lot of this as a
young kid and it was comical you know
it's like who you're fighting over the
dishes and I don't get to sleep with my
wife tonight that's you know he gets my
my roommate does ah you know it's hard
you know
um yeah uh you know and a lot of things
get in the way I think that you know I I
forgive me but you know I think of the
U.S and how much of United States
culture is designed around you know the
nuclear monogamous family of you know
single homes
suburbs driving in a car
um you know really structured around
that and and maybe that's poor design it
doesn't seem to fit our evolutionary
past of being
in these you know these collectives that
are sharing in the raising of Offspring
and
um and sharing and to a certain extent
in romantic partnership so are you
married yes you've been married for a
long time yeah they're uh 90 I think
it's 33 years wow geez yeah important
context yeah
some people might you know
think that um you were like
anti-marriage or anything like that but
you're clearly I can see from the room
in your face yeah but I grew up around a
mom who you know she taught women's
literature and feminism in the 70s and
you know that early feminist critique of
marriage is right you know early on it
it women did a lot of the work it
constrained them it cost them in terms
of job uh mobility and so
I've always questioned it and then I
think the evolutionary literature we
talked about is like wait a minute maybe
love is more distributed it comes in
many varieties and that's how we get
this love work done so I'm glad you guys
are questioning it seriously
yeah good luck yeah the good thing is
we're really like we're really open to
new things as in we're open to like
building new systems for our
relationship in the modern world based
on how we feel we're very good at being
um resistant to like social pressure to
to follow a a conventional path yeah so
even with Valentine's days and things
like that we have a conversation about
like does this make sense like why would
we do this and yeah what's more
important yeah which a lot of people
don't I've been in relationships before
where you you don't hit the perfect like
a social Cube to show up or give flowers
or whatever and you get like a
an essay and you're you know a bad guy
for that day but um okay Max one of the
points you said you were talking about
how men in particular struggle to show
Express those emotions yeah
um and you know stereotypically we're
not as affectionate and kind as as our
female counterparts one of the things
that you talk about is the difference in
social class yeah yeah and how things
change oh man oh
are we
worst people of richer and more powerful
we become
because your research seems to show that
yeah
I would say yes
um and I'm sorry to say that you know
it's it's uh you know we
um
uh I got interested in social class
um actually living in England you know I
lived in England in 1978
um and the United States is very blind
to social class we're now more aware of
it Bernie Sanders Etc rightfully so one
percent critique
you know 80s 90s were just blind to it
as a morgalitarian time and I lived in
Nottingham England very working-class
town in a very tough time in England's
history of you know coal strikes and the
like and it was tough and and the
English
had this
um just much more sophisticated
understanding of class and
differentiations between on the Dole and
working class and Posh and you know all
these categories I was like Wow classes
everywhere it affects how people speak
and dress and eat and so forth and so we
started to apply social class to what
we've been talking about like The
Compassion ah gratitude empathy kindness
sharing altruism and just you know
across
um
studies and and you know largely in the
United States I think you could question
whether this applies to Holland or UK or
Japan where there there's less
inequality I might add
um you know as you rise in wealth and
privilege you share a less you feel less
compassion to images of suffering
you know you see an image this was a
striking study to me of you know it's a
movie about a child who has cancer and
poorer people show activation of the
vagus nerve which is part of compassion
you know causes you to like want to help
well-to-do people less activation uh
they feel less awe as you rise in the
social class hierarchy in the United
States
are more impolite and so that was part
of my power Paradox book was that story
about the class I you know I I hesitate
I worry about like in my worst person
and I you I'd rather use your earlier
language of like what are the structural
conditions that get in the way of this
and you think about you know
rising in in wealth and privilege in
class is introduce you create a life
that makes it harder to be kind you know
that you're people are assisting you
with things and
um you don't come into contact with
suffering you know you live in a
neighborhood in the United States or
probably UK where it's like you don't
see it you know and so it doesn't train
those Tendencies and you know frankly
um Stephen I you know I think this is
increasingly true in the UK but in the
United States uh you know with one in
six people impoverished
uh life expectancy's dropping you know
six seven hundred thousand unhoused
people in the United States where I live
Berkeley California everywhere you go
you're bumping into somebody who doesn't
have a home
I I think it's our Central failure in
the U.S is
how
privilege has short-circuited our our
better
human tendencies
how do we know that
it's the increase in wealth and social
class
that is causing us to become less kind
and less empathetic less compassionate
or it's just go further yeah
yeah there's a distinction there like
maybe these people were always
and that's why they became successful or
rich or wealthy or whatever or or in a
higher social class yeah I I mean
they're too and that's a critical
question right and and people have long
championed this idea that well maybe all
of this what it really tells us is you
you if you practice our compassion you
don't rise in the ranks and you don't
gain wealth and the like and there are
two rebuttals to that idea the first
which I chart in the power Paradox which
people still don't believe too much but
on balance today
um people who practice empathy who
listen and and share resources practice
gratitude rise in the ranks they they do
better in social hierarchies and that
replicates in a lot of contexts and and
really what happens is is this is why I
call it the power paradoxes once I have
everybody's respect and you know wealth
and the like then it I tend to misbehave
right in the ways we've talked about
through a lot of different uh uh forms
of unethical Behavior the other rebuttal
is we've actually done experiments right
and you can take a middle class
individual and you can get them into the
mindset like hey you're actually
have a lot of Advantage vis-a-vis most
of society through simple manipulations
right just think about how you compare
to a lot of poor people and they're like
oh I'm doing really well and that simple
shift in mindset leads to reduced
compassion reduced empathy so you can
you can actually move people around
where you give them the sense that
they're privileged and it tends to
undermine these these Tendencies Jesus I
know it is and you know
um I worry about it I worry about it a
lot what
um you know the the kind of poor
distribution of privilege in the United
States and increasing UK and other
countries is doing to the social fabric
it's it's uh problematic it's
interesting because there is there's
kind of a long um prevailing stereotype
that rich people are
like bad like yeah less compassionate
um less empathetic and I and I always
wondered whether that was just I don't
know was it true was it
um was it was it people being jealous
was it
um just too much of a broad
generalization was that you know based
on the acts of maybe a few yeah but
you're telling me that the science
supports the fact that generally the
more the Richer you are and the how you
are in terms of social class and the
less compassionate less empathetic you
are as a human yeah you know and it is
that I mean that's the broad argument
I've given you a couple of findings here
there are all kinds of other findings
that speak to this Jesus um you know one
this is one of my favorites is you know
in these um these epidemiologists who
are studying broad Trends and social
behavior discovered this accidentally
they're interested in whose shoplifts as
a teenager in the United States you know
a basic unethical tendency really costly
for businesses in the United States is
it the rich picture the poor
well you know what who I do I would
assume it would be but I feel like I'm
wrong
it's the rich rich high school kids in
the United States are more likely to
shoplift right
and that's striking they've got their
parents credit card they can buy
whatever they want and they violate that
social rule this is where it gets really
worrisome my former student Michael
Krauss did really nice work
on U.S senators and U.S policy makers
you know American politicians are rich
they increasingly so and he was simply
interested in does your degree of
privilege or wealth predict
regressive policy preferences like let's
not give resources to schools for the
poor let's not fund you know Medicare
let's really move wealth through
taxation policies to the well to do and
the wealthier you are the more you produ
you preferred and advocated for
you know serious economic policies that
hurt the poor and benefit the well to do
who already have you know in the US the
one percent they have enough they have
more than enough right why not share a
little so it's deep and I think and then
you look across history
European aristocracies and you know the
popes and so forth and it's it's I think
it's one of the you know frankly Stephen
and I hate to say it you know Lord Acton
uh you know power leads to abuse and
absolute power absolute corruption our
power is corrupting
um it's a pretty safe law in human
behavior
I hate to say it it's because you're
rising in prominence and facing a new
life and you better watch out yeah I
think most of the time you're talking
which is like how do you avoid that how
do you avoid yeah how do you avoid the
uh that
scientifically supported tendency to
become an with with the more
wealth and power you accrue
um I guess my my assumption was just
being conscious of the fact yeah the
first thing yeah but also just like
there's probably act things you could do
actively to remain
uh
uh aware of your own
insignificance maybe not the word yeah
like the fact that everybody is exactly
the same yeah it's like the way I
describe it yeah I mean I think that
there's an awareness Dimension to this
that you've suggested
there's an ethical practice of like how
do I create more gratitude in an
organization if that's what we care
about
Etc
um how do I counteract my own biases
then as well so yeah how do I put you
people around me who represent and we're
thinking here I'm thinking here about
governments that represent the entirety
of the population not just the rich
private school right colleagues that I
might surround myself with which has
often been the case in government and
that is hard to work against right that
is a deep sociological process that like
you appoint the cabinet member from
Oxford or whatever and you're in trouble
yeah you know it's it's uh
it is uh you know a lot of economists a
lot of the work coming out of um you
know spirit level UK this is a central
challenge of of the structure of our
societies today it's this this
increasingly unequal distribution of
privilege and wealth and all that goes
with it to people that are wealthy and
in higher social class live longer
because I say that because the the
attributes are becoming less empathetic
and rude around these things seem to be
the antithesis of Social connectedness
and yeah all of these things and you
even said earlier that you know
wealthier people experience less all
yeah and all of those things are
um uh are associated with living longer
yeah so one would assume that if you
become rich and Powerful you're then
there's also then also a risk to your
life expectancy yeah that's terrific
that's a really striking question and we
don't know
um and I think your reasoning is right
on the point which is wow you
have less friends right privilege knocks
out these these these important
tendencies that help with inflammation
and vagal tone and the like
um rich people do live longer
um that's right yeah yeah and food you
eat and so forth sure
um you know opportunity for health you
know yoga all the things that benefit us
um uh rich people this is interesting
um surprised me rich people are less
likely to experience anxiety and
depression in the United States yeah
interesting isn't it we think so lonely
and anxiety producing to be at the top
no mental health issues are really
concentrated in the poor for obvious
reasons working two jobs riding the bus
you know schools are under resource Etc
but to your point and it's interesting
the effect of wealth on happiness is
much smaller than people think people
think you know in particular in a
country like the United Kingdom or you
know Great Britain or U.S like
um once I make a lot of money
it'll be Bliss and happiness and
contentment that turns out not to be
true it's a weak relationship and I
think part of the reason is
you know when you you gain in resources
you don't have these raw feelings of
compassion as often or God I'm grateful
for that gift right that you gave me or
this is awesome this person's courage or
how they overcome overcame obstacles and
so that diminishes how wealth could make
you happier so I think it's at play in
some of these phenomena and maybe in
others
as some of you will know Intel have been
sponsoring this podcast for a little
while now and this makes the search for
high spec laptops super easy because all
you have to do is look for the Intel Evo
badge and you'll have everything you
need the thing that's great about the
Intel Evo platform is that you still
have so much choice and that's key for
me there are now over a hundred designs
that have been Intel Evo certified so
you can quite literally find the perfect
laptop for you amongst that vast
selection now I've got two in front of
me here one is the Samsung Galaxy book
360 which rotates over 360 degrees and
is amazing for things like teen
presentations meetings and Etc also
really great for keeping podcast notes
on when you're sat with a guest but I
personally use the Dell XPS because it's
lightweight super lightweight and its
battery lasts for over 9 hours even
while you have multiple tabs open which
helps to to stay at the pace that I run
out in my day-to-day life so to find out
more and get your hands on your own
Intel Evo laptop head over to
intel.co.uk Evo right now let me know
how you get on I've now been a cool
Drinker for about four years roughly so
much so that I ended up investing in the
company
um and I play a role on the board of the
company but they also very kindly
sponsor this podcast and to be honest
I've never said this before but he all
believed in this podcast before anybody
else the CEO Julian
um told me before we even launched the
podcast how successful it would be and
that Hill would back it and I absolutely
have a huge amount of gratitude for them
for that support but an even greater
sense of gratitude for the fact that
they've helped me stay nutritionally
complete throughout the chaos and
hecticness of my tremendously busy
business schedule so if you haven't
tried out here which I hope most of you
have at least given it a go by now try
it out it's an unbelievable way to try
and stay nutritionally on course if you
have a hectic busy schedule and let me
know what you think send me a tweet and
a DM tag me let me know what you think
back to the podcast
you talked about how life expectancy's
been declining in the last few years why
yeah you know in the United States
um and I don't know the data in the UK
um and and it's um it's it's really
related to inequality and opportunity
and the poor distribution or uh of of
opportunity and resources is um there
have been these amazing findings
uh related to what's called Death by
despair
and certain populations in the United
States
um very poor white people large group of
the large subculture in the United
States
are often forgotten in the cultural
discourse they're poor I grew up around
these people
very poor don't eat good food schools
are not that good you know work is
uncertain
and they and they feel disrespected in
some sense and those that subculture in
the U.S has been killing themselves you
know with opiates and you know drinking
and drug addiction and suicides and the
like and it's a serious problem and it's
part of that statistic
and then I think that you know if you
think about the problems of contemporary
culture concentrated in the United
States of
lack of Civility rage self-focus a lot
of things
that undermine our physical health
through the mind
um that probably is part of this story
too too much stress too much loneliness
um not enough music and joy and shared
communal experience
um we are struggling
um and and that's part of probably that
statistic too and so that's why you know
as I mentioned like the Surgeon General
Vivek Murthy a very smart team looking
at these kind of processes and saying
how do we build community you know and
they're they've got a big program now so
it is alarming and that statistic
is important for I think thinking about
where we are I looked at the life
expectancy on Google a couple of years
ago and I I could see that it was
basically going up every single year
yeah and then there was these two years
I think it might have been last year the
year before this was I think before the
pandemic
um there was these two years where it
had dropped both in the UK and the US
yeah in a row yeah
um and I was trying to understand why
that was and I heard some social
commentators say that there's this
epidemic of purposelessness yeah yeah
and describe that as leading to the
opioid crisis but also suicides and all
these other behaviors yeah
um
is that is that a good way to in your in
your view to Define it like this
epidemic of purposelessness yeah it is
you know thanks for bringing that up and
you know purpose a lot of people now
call it meaning yeah right what vague
term has many different definitions but
it's you know I as an individual how do
I connect to things that are larger than
the self that don't have to do with
income or status or directly but like
what's my point here in my brief life on
Earth
um you know what am I going to serve
what's the big cause that I'm part of
and this is really emerging in the
science of Happiness as a central focus
of you know
um you know we we know well uh how to
find income we have good ideas about
sensory Pleasures what's good to eat how
do I drink wines what's the great coffee
and the like
but we've lost sight of meaning you know
churches and religions used to give that
to us you know and religious
participation is on the decline in the
west dramatically so for people your age
um where they gave us a big picture of
life and now
you know young people are hungry for it
and they're challenging
a lot of the the approaches to happiness
that that don't give meaning you know
new conceptions of work like I don't
have to stay at one career if it isn't
meaningful new conceptions of romantic
relationship and so
I think you know I think a lot of
different perspectives are saying this
is
one of the crises of our times is
meaning is what will be the big thing
you're devoted to
if you went to Father how would you
answer that question uh which question
what are you devoted to I'm devoted to
so many things I'm devoted to this this
this podcast in the show for so many
reasons for very selfish reasons but
those selfish reasons happen to be
selfless yeah a lot you see what I mean
like yeah doing the podcast I know helps
helps the people some of the people that
listen because they come up to me in the
street and they tell me all the time
wherever I go and the stories they tell
me are like uh I remember I was at um
Old Trafford
uh two days ago the Manchester United
stadium and a guy who was the he said he
was the nearest Survivor to the
Manchester
um terrorist attacks
um approached me in his in his
wheelchair and told me that of the
impact this has had on him yeah and I
literally had to walk like I took the
fight with him walked um like two meters
out out into this um this balcony and I
remember feeling just overwhelmed with
emotion and it was this wonderful
reminder of like
how why I do this yeah for both the
listener but also for me so this is
something that I'm increasingly devoted
to because of those experiences and
thank you to that young man he's tweeted
me about for doing that because I needed
I needed the reminder I feel like you
need the reminders sometimes often I'm
devoted to my relationship with my
partner my dog my family yeah
um my team
and I'm I'm devoted to myself I'm
devoted to like my my um Health my you
know of both my body and my mind yeah
I think that's what I'm devoted to and I
think I'm devoted to
um
the the yeah probably answer this in the
first piece but the the greater good of
like the collective so yeah
you know
um yeah and you know it's so interesting
you know Stephen one of the reasons that
I got really excited about awe as an
emotion to study a brief state that you
you know you go out and you see the the
moment of generosity that you saw or
look at the sky or you know think about
a big idea the idea of space or
Infinities is it does bring people it
kind of moves people away from
transactional considerations so in one
of our studies look up into the trees
you feel oh you're less interested in
money you're less focused on the self
and you're you're really more focused on
the greater good like what how do my
actions promote healthier societies
um and and I think that
um you know a lot of of young people are
raising questions of meaning right now
with climate crises and economic
inequality the state of democracy like
what is the point you know when you know
you think about conversations
from the last century in the centuries
before you know in reading for all
people would use words like the soul
yeah and spirit and like this is what
I'm really about in life uh and we've
lost sight of that you know and so
hopefully with this book people how
whatever language they want to use
they're asking questions like
what am I devoted to what's sacred what
is why do people suddenly care it seems
like this young generation Millennials
and yeah gen Z they all want to change
the world yeah now they don't
necessarily know what they want to
change yeah but they want to be involved
in the process and this is literally a
quote and I say this because of the
amount of young people that come up to
me various times DM me and said I said
like what you want to do they they'll
say things like I want to change the
world yeah
how do you want to change it and they're
like they don't know they don't know but
they want to be involved in changing the
world yeah I've always wondered if this
is like virtue signaling because it's
good for social media probably probably
right yeah or there's been some inherent
change you know from my father's
generation to my future kids generation
and my generation where we suddenly are
these great philanthropists and we yeah
yeah change everything yeah no it's
exciting for me I mean you know the and
there are a lot of good findings on this
that when Thatcher and Reagan hit in
1980 and that's when I was 18 right we
had this big return to materialism and
you think about the movie Wall Street
being iconic greed is good and that
truly that was the idea right of like
the point of life is selfish genes and
maximizing my wealth and we had this
massive you know shift in Wall Street
and that became our ideology and that's
been documented sociologically like in
my generation
you know suddenly coming out of the 60s
and all the social Revolutions of those
times now young people are allowed to
say I want to make a ton of money I want
to live in a big house I want to you
know I want to drive whatever car and
your generation is reacting against that
big pendulum shift right and suddenly
it's like hey that didn't work look at
the Amazon look at economic inequality
Bernie Sanders right what about climate
crises Greta tunberg right suddenly new
model and it's it's coming but it's not
because of social it feels like that
social media and the internet has played
a huge role in yeah making us this like
one Connected Mind yeah and we know from
our sort of evolutionary past that we we
prefer members of the the true tribe
that are that serve the tribe that are
good yeah you know that are I think
there's a there's a term you use when
we're talking when you're talking about
gossip
um how we will gossip against people who
are not doing good for the tribe
essentially yes so we know that like
being part of the tribe and serving the
tribe and being you know empathetic and
caring about others is a good trait now
we're all connected on these glass
screens as if we're one brain and we're
rewarded with these likes and these
retweets and we do good yeah so if I if
I you know if I do something really good
for society or whatever
um then I'm rewarded with I don't know
comments or likes whatever or you know
everyone collapse and I feel part of the
tribe yeah so is social media made us
these philanthropic Warriors that are
seeking for ways to like virtually
signal our goodness yeah
you know I I mean there's one argument
in that in general any Act of virtue and
way of promoting the greater good
becomes co-opted and exploited by people
who have power you know and there's a
critique you know I hate to say this but
you have a lot of non-profits that they
kind of they create these virtuous
organizations and pay people good
salaries and don't do a lot in the world
and that is a critique out there and I
think it could be even more robustly
uh levied against the digital virtue is
like it's I it you could say it's
meaningless let's take that hypothesis
right oh we we turn acts of generosity
and kindness and appreciation that you
saw on the train into digital things
that don't affect anything right black
lives matter everyone was told to post a
black tile on their Instagram on a
Tuesday
like I did a post about how um how much
that misses the point in many respects
yeah if we're trying to deal with
systemic racism yeah posting a black
tile on a Tuesday really does nothing to
um address and evoke the conversation
that needs to be had yeah but it was
like an easy quick yeah cool way to say
I'm a good person it's and to do very
little thereafter you know and if it's
not changing hiring practices or PA
practices or school admissions it is BS
and it's a and and probably counter
works against social progress I had a
call during that time from one of the
biggest brands in the world who who
asked me on a conference call
um there's five of them what should we
do you know we need do we do we do a
donation what should we post on our
Twitter Channel like what should we do
and say and part of you know it was the
five Executives at this huge company and
I said I think the most important thing
is actually to get your home in order
first it's startling that there's five
white men on this phone call right now
talking about
um race relations
and inequality I think it's it's better
not to be the contradictions it's better
to get your home in order first before
you start
you know and that's not I mean there's
you can almost see the expression in
their faces it's like oh that's so hard
that's the hard thing we'll get to work
yeah exactly it's much easier just to do
a donation right in those situations I
want to talk about um compassion yeah
it's a word I've struggled to understand
if I'm honest yeah because like what
does it mean does it mean being nice to
people no you know
um compassion is
um the feeling of concern about other
people's suffering okay and and then
taking action right uh empathy empathy
is
I feel the same thing as you I
understand your mental States if you're
in pain I feel pain compassion is you're
in pain and I want to I want to make
your circumstances better I want to lift
up your your well-being
um so it's interesting um compassion is
a very Dynamic emotion it's an empowered
emotion it isn't nice is great you know
it's politeness and Civility and being
considered I think we uh we need more
niceness in the world and I think we
often I think the connotations of the
word nice
uh sort of devalue how powerful it is
but compassion is powerful it is the
state of wanting to lift up the welfare
of other people who suffer
um and what's striking about it and and
I love the neurophysiology of this and
that the which really speaks to its
power which is that
I can see somebody suffering dying
cancer
Flesh Wounds crying in pain and when I
lock into the compassion response
certain regions of the brain are
activated that are different than
empathy the vagus nerve is activated and
it's it really just throws you into
altruistic action right so
um and that's why you know when the
Dalai Lama
um you know who's now one of the most
prominent spiritual figures in the world
says if you want others to be happy
practice compassion
and if you want to be happy practice
compassion
that gets to it right like man if you
can stay close to compassion
you and other people and the greater
good will do well it's a really Dynamic
emotion is there scientific evidence
that proves that you will become happier
if you're compassionate to others yeah
and what does that scientific evidence
show improve it's amazing you know and
it it begins with a study by Liz Dunn
famous study replicated in many
different cultures which is you give
people some money and they can give it
away to us to help somebody or spend it
on themselves giving it away boosts
happiness more than spending it on
yourself
there's research I love this work and
contagion has been part of our
experience here where
um if I am kind to You Stephen
um this is kind of extending from the
study
uh that boosts my life expectancy it
shifts my physiology it shifts my stress
but I love this work where if I'm kind
to you and then the experimenter watches
you in your next interaction you're
kinder to that person right I'm not
around my act of kindness makes you more
kind Downstream and then that person
you've helped actually is Kinder to
another person in a subsequent
interaction so you know they're proving
that yeah and really nice research on
the contagiousness of altruism and
compassion
um yeah it is like gratitude it's one of
these big Winners you know if I there's
a loving kindness practice
where comes out of East Asian traditions
where you just calm yourself get into
some deep breathing find a quiet safe
space
and Orient kind phrases to other people
I I may you be filled with loving
kindness may you be safe from inner
outer danger well and body and mind at
ease and happy and that simple practice
two minutes right uh just calms the
amygdala threat related region of the
brain activates reward circuitry so
you know
um you know you talked about and you
asked about what are these structural
conditions of our busy lives that get in
the way of of the good life and you've
got to find a few moments just to be
kind
I was blown away
um when reading your your work and
watching videos that you produced about
um so many things the one of the real
startling things is the the power of
touch yeah
I read I read um that if you pat a kid
on the back in the classroom that child
is three to four five times more likely
to try hard problems on the Blackboard
and that touch can make you live longer
and be less stressed just someone
touching you yeah is that true yeah I
mean it's you know
touch in a lot of mammalian species
including humans is just connection it's
it's identity it's I'm with you you know
you think early in life we are
constantly being held and in skin to
skin contact with our caregivers it's
foundational it's where my sense of me
and you connection emerges the
physiology of touch is mind-blowing you
know our hands are incredible they're
spectacular
um you know evolutionary adaptations
they can do all kinds of things
including touch our skin eight pounds
billions of cells our immune system is
in the skin you know it registers touch
in many different ways from the sexual
to the friendly to The Cooperative goes
up into the brain and says man you're
being touched in this way
uh and and that has Direct effects on
your immune system and your vagus nerve
and your heart rate and the health of
your body and so you know early
discoveries
um you know you have premature babies
they're gonna die
and and they used to just put them in
these little you know
um sort of units that warm them and had
them sort of be comfortable and fed and
they would die and then they figured out
you gotta hold the premature baby they
needed skin to skin contact like they
need food right and they live they gain
47 weight gain
um and then you know they're they're
just studies time and time again
you know nice uh lower cortisol uh nice
Embrace with somebody elevated vagal
tone
um the studies that you referred to of
you know patting kids on the back they
they do better in school
um you know and it's so interesting
parts of
English culture you know Victorian
culture Western European culture they
came up with the idea like touches
sexual it's you got to get it and it is
but only certain kinds of tetosexual
there's a lot of friendly touch we need
right and it just shut it down
and now it's coming back it's uh thank
goodness it's it's good for us we we
talked before we start filming about the
study with the Recess Monkeys yeah I
can't remember that through who the
researcher was but yeah I was saying to
that Harlow Harlow that was it yeah
um how that was mind-blowing to me at 16
to learn that they put these monkeys in
these cages they had like a pretend wire
mother so a mother made out of like
metal and then they had another one made
out of like cloth yeah like a mother
made out of cloth which was essentially
a teddy bear and there was huge variance
between the outcomes of those kids right
yeah I mean if you defrive those monkeys
of the nice touch
they they don't learn how to behave
socially effectively you know if you
give them a choice between a wire uh
monkey mother and that provides milk and
then a terry cloth one they always hang
around the terry cloth one right they
just love the social contact if you
deprive non-human primates of touch they
they are almost schizophrenic or
Psychopathic or they're just like
personality disorder aggressive they
can't handle social interactions you
know orphans deprived of touch famous
orphan studies
you know in human same thing they just
like they don't become human in some way
or they are human but they have trouble
with social contact yeah you know I mean
part of the questioning of that you're
engaging in Stephen or the literature is
like well what can I do just to live a
more meaningful life and you know from
gratitude to kindness to find some ah
man you know
if you're not hugging people you love if
you're not if you don't have a rich
language of touch with your friends you
know I learned at playing pickup
basketball basketball which is the I
believe the most
fascinating sport in human history it
has this amazing language of touch you
know and it's it's Unique to the court
right you're fist bumping chest bumping
and the like if you're not doing that
with your friends you're missing out on
one of the great languages of human
kind which is to be in contact with each
other so you know parents
you know when you have kids
and I hope some of your listeners are
doing that you know it's this mystery
like
should they take naps on my body should
we how should I hold them should I carry
them in public am I indulging them and I
think the more friendly kind touch the
better so we're moving back to where we
began evolutionarily and I think it'll
be a good thing but if I'm touching a
dog
yeah I mean dogs evolved yeah because we
love them and they love us and there's
all this new amazing dog science where
this is one of my favorite studies and
touch releases oxytocin uh which is this
little chemical that floats in your
brain in your blood and it helps you be
kind to other people and cooperate and
there are now studies from Japan showing
you may do this with your dog Steven
where if you look into the eyes of your
dog
you your dog will have a surge of
oxytocin and you will have a surge of
oxytocin so
so it's like all of this social stuff
that's so simple of eye contact and
touch uh brings us good things even with
our dogs
it makes me kind of realize two things
the first is that men tend to be
stereotypically much worse at that yeah
much worse at touch we don't we we do
the like the Macho Hub where you like on
the back you know like we Pat them in
the back and say get the off me
um we're we're less good at even things
like eye contact yeah sort of emotional
engagement and then you look at the
stats around male suicides and all of
those you know uh drug addiction and all
those things and it's significantly
higher yeah I think I believe the stats
say that the biggest killer of men under
the age of 40 is themselves in this
country Yeah by Suicide um
and they really need Fields like they
need to be a reversal of that yeah the
adjacent point is it just the one we
talked about earlier which is just
loneliness yeah and now it kind of makes
sense as to why
if you are lonely you have a
significantly worth worse Health
outcomes
um and a shorter life expectancy because
you're not getting the compassion the
touch you're not you're probably
experiencing less or gratitude Etc yeah
um and I feel like we have to we have to
talk about how we fix that yeah like you
know because some of the saddest moments
I can I think about when I've had
private conversations are men coming up
to me after like a talk on stage and
whispering to me that the part I said
about me being lonely when I was like 23
24 and I'd given everything just for
this business coming to the office every
day sacrifice friendships family
relationships
I'll have men come up to me and whisper
to me that that was the part that they
um it needed to hear the most but then
asking me what they can actionably do to
fix that yeah as if they don't want the
the group around me to hear that they
are lonely yeah and they want to do
something about it they are sat on their
computers often playing video games or
on the Internet
um struggling to attract you know maybe
the opposite sex or the same sex or
whatever whatever they're interested in
and it feels like it's going in one
negative Direction generally I mean the
stats kind of support yeah the fact that
we're getting lonelier and lonelier yeah
yeah I mean those are such deep insights
um
and uh really worth thinking more
concretely about what to do I think that
the you know kind of the the gender
complexities here are really striking
right men live significantly fewer years
than women in most western globalized
cultures and and I think you're on a
really interesting hypothesis Steven
which is that
you know if the gender stereotypes and
these rigid Concepts and then The Lies
We lead don't allow us to hug and feel
grateful and feel empathetic it
countervails that and they're those are
gender stereotypes right oh if I
practice compassion at work I'll be weak
and I won't rise that's not true that's
a gender stereotype and it it denies men
um disproportionately this opportunity
for these emotions right and that's that
you know with new conceptions of gender
new ideas about work is changing
dramatically uh that will shift and I
think it'll be good news for the health
of men
um and and then loneliness
um loneliness in some sense is the
deprivation of everything we've been
talking about it's that you don't get to
hug somebody like you would like to
every day and that you don't hear the
words of appreciation William James you
know the deepest craving we have is to
be appreciated by other people you don't
hear it you don't hear the thank you you
don't get to go out and feel awe with
somebody or feel kindness
um you know so I think we have to
think very actively about building these
emotions into those contexts in the
United States
there are 35
000 long-term care facilities
the elderly in the United States
a lot of them live alone you know if
when people from India
see how we treat the elderly or people
from Mexico
it's just like the unhoused they're like
what are you guys doing you know you're
taking the vulnerable
and and sort of shunting them off alone
but the but these emotions point to
really direct actionable things to do
right with awe practices and compassion
so it gives me hope but we've got you
know I think in part historically we
took these pro-social emotions out of
our lives
right and now we gotta build them back
in and if we do it's good for not just
ourselves but it's good for the
recipients of those emotions you know
hugging hugging my dad or hugging my mom
or hugging anybody is is a mutually
beneficial
um behavior in terms of all the you know
life expectancy happiness reduction in
stress and not only that but you know I
just heard 50 of U.S Healthcare expenses
are on the last five years of life when
a lot of those people are living alone
and feeling lonely and there are simple
ways to address that as we've been
talking about so it's it there's a
bottom line that's really relevant here
too and then the the really the the bit
I imagine a lot of people will
especially those that I'm much more
spiritually inclined will love is the
idea of that Karma and how you know if I
hug one person or if I'm kind of some
person or Express that gratitude or
compassion it has this sort of cascading
knock-on effect yeah and how they go
through the day so like in that sense
karma is a very real thing it's very
real yeah in every respect even in the
in the the con concept of Gossip where
how you treat someone will spread I
think you said in your your book that
um when we treat someone badly
people on average gossip that bad
treatment to 2.5 people yeah which is
you know which is slightly terrifying
but it's but it makes sense
um
yeah you know it's in part of our theme
in our conversation is how we're all
connected and United in these these
super organisms some people call them
through practicing gratitude and sharing
resources that spreads through uh these
social networks and then the the
compliment is also true which is you
know and and as much as I don't like
gossip and I didn't like being gossiped
about it's a human Universal it can be
horrifying and and we've got to worry
about it like online cat fights and ah
that it escalates but we study these
social groups and and the thing that
people really gossip about is when
you're not kind right they're like
look at what that that person just said
these harsh things that spreads through
the network and it
tries to keep those problematic
tendencies in check I guess that's a
good thing it's like a community sort of
Regulation tool yeah
thank you so much I've had a wonderful a
brilliant time over the last week
learning more and more about all of your
work and reading and watching your your
content in great detail this book is
absolutely fantastic
um it's very challenging but it's this
this concept of all was one was not one
that I'd ever thought of before you know
you think about these other sort of
emotions gratitude compassion there's a
lot written about them but yeah I've
almost never heard someone talk about
the topic of all as a very accessible
but very profound powerful human
medicine I would say and the way that
you do that throughout your book is um
is incredibly important and I've as I
said I've really never encountered a
book quite like it so I highly recommend
everybody goes and gives it a try and
the reviews on the back by people like
Adam Grant and Stephen Pinker
I mean they speak for themselves so
thank you for writing such a brilliant
book and thank you for having such a
brilliant eye-opening conversation with
me today we have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest
huh okay funny
um the question that's been left
for you
is
do you think obesity
is a choice
[Laughter]
um
it's a terrific question right and
obesity is I think in the U.S I think
the latest estimate's 56 of U.S citizens
probably pretty comparable here in the
UK
um and man when I think about the food
that we put into our bodies
the lack of activity that are not chosen
right that depend on what kind of soft
drink that's readily available and cheap
and how fast food is so cheap and
provide us provides us a certain kind of
high to me that says that it's mainly
not a choice of the people eating but it
is a choice of the policy makers so I
would make that
argument
and there is some sort of three lines
between the conversation we've had today
about stress connectedness and all of
those things very much yes to food and
diet and anything which is again social
constructs and and access to Art
um there is a movement Parks living near
Parks London is one of the greenest
cities in the world living near Parks
boosts life expectancy I think through
awe uh there's a movement in the united
in California that everybody should be
10 minutes public transport away from a
park for free
um 360 million people uh went to the
national parks in the United States last
year so there's a lot of
with this stress profile that we've been
talking about culturally they're easy
solutions and one and one pathways
through being outdoors with all
I want to close in just on that point
about yeah a sort of an adjacent Point
what you've just said which is about and
you also talked about prisoners earlier
I read once upon a time when I was doing
some research for one of my books that
um prisoners who had a exposure to
nature yeah were significantly less
likely to become depressed than those
that were like basically looking out at
concrete yeah
um
which is mind-blowing to me it is the
thought that just seeing nature can have
a massive impact on our our chances of
depression and anxiety yeah
do we need to put more of that stuff in
prison sir we do we do and that you know
you've been challenging me Stephen like
all right what do we do just look at a
hospital put some nature in it right
look at a prison prisons are horrifying
in the United States Norway has more
open prisons with views and so forth uh
different recidivism rates so I take
from this science and I'm really
grateful to you for profiling it you
know in such a
uh uh scholarly and thoughtful way like
we got to use this knowledge and prisons
is a nice application but even in our
own homes yeah you know we most of us
are living in these white boxes in big
cities and those that live in social
housing unfortunately are living in even
worse conditions often yeah
um and nature is somewhat of a privilege
it seems it shouldn't be especially in
the home environment just having some
plants I have zero in here I have loads
upstairs because I have a girlfriend and
she's just she's very in touch with
those things but she's she's filled my
house with with plants but yeah that's a
simple thing we can all do to be happier
every day is just have a bit more nature
and our in our environment it's not a
bad First Step okay thank you so much
thank you Steven it's been an honor and
a pleasure
foreign
from one of our sponsors I've got a tip
for all of you that will make your
virtual meeting experiences I think 10
times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
[Music]
foreign